well things could get worse on a what
shot me he shot Ross it's a shut up
going in the neck what was that noise
hello welcome to random encounter the
weekly live streaming show on gamespot
com and two HR TV for SAS gamespot we
play a different random video game my
name is Daniel O'Dwyer i'm joined by our
resident tex murphy experts Benito
Gonzalez I guess that's as close as I
can get like to being an expert at
typing X Murphy well we're gonna play
the Tesla effect a tex murphy adventure
which i believe is technically the sixth
game yeah what do things look hot just
go down we could probably find we can
probably find the work work building
was a time when I would have never
agreed to do something that's despicable
I can't explain what I do this but maybe
Judas would understand
alright so i can right click ok so you
right click on anything and just shows
your option controlling your flashlight
be like yo what stuff I think somebody's
shouting on me it was using for your
phone glue is always useful that is true
adventure games you pick up anything
you're allowed to pick up yeah what the
[ __ ] is that here's the phone hmm no
messages on the bid for this mother door
thanks I mean that's just nice coming
from outside thanks and I don't like
computer maybe it's anybody's wipe my
computer clean sons of [ __ ] damn it i
don't like episodes of game of thrones
on that I wonder how much this
characters based on like the designers
own tastes and loves on what it does I'm
sure there's a lot of like Roger so I
was finishing up the latest on my wire
kids adventure on I realized I can buck
I devoured several chapters and it
wasn't agreeing with me I give just a
stomach-churning like a volcano and I
realized how are they gonna make it to
the bathroom Oh what I'll get you mithi
if he's the last thing I you shud oh
yeah yeah it's kind of in a source
button our relationship ever since
that's uh let's investigate the scene
where is he he's up at the wynn gonna
flashback yeah PTSD yeah for speeding
headlights coming together though the
Wardenclyffe tower Nick I think it's the
Wardenclyffe tower a nickel a Tesla
invention the strangest feeling this is
related to a case I was working on well
the name of the game is a test of fact
so there's something like a dumpster
escaped unscathed motor oil the secret
ingredient to Louise Armageddon blend
deathly up at this time so this right
here this is a game like you're just
looking at stuff you're finding clues
ruins 2 i'm here to see my pal Louie but
I see a pretty brunette this is like a
reoccurring character alright I think
she recognizes me I have no idea she
also go into video and how is it yeah
yeah yeah this is rad Wow hello stranger
yeah ang me this totally feels like a
dream yeah that has got to be the nicest
thing you've ever said to me just for
that I'm gonna get you some coffee uh
what's it I love how vague these uh yeah
metaphor or like an act like that sure i
like it like my heart black this is
hella weird this is yeah all right yes I
say yes all right I'm gonna go buzz kill
oh man oh my joke is that blood hush
you're not picking fights again
I don't know what happened but you look
pretty incredible nurses this is really
where do huh in the mood for a little
role-playing who do you think you are
mr. this is really weird I feel you're
the God the hell's going on uh-uh see
using these situations i'd pick the
weirdest one oh boy get all weird uh
stranger danger I don't know I don't
want to ruin this moment I gotta turn
tables you see me know who I am who are
you I'm Taylor and I'll be your nurse I
recommend two aspirin I think she wants
to get but I think boning is on her I
have to investigate these gunshots but
maybe if I were to do it really quick oh
all you have to go into work today
unfortunately but maybe have to work
tomorrow she's gonna call me in the
morning I knew this guy isn't it work I
couldn't send it to your smart girl
notice gmail has a dr w at the North
Hill clinic call me after and tell me
what she says about that noggin of yours
see Uncle Louie I see it Hannah oh say
his Louise nice Oh Oh Louie you ain't
lookin to wash my is uh isn't even ok
are you doing here what are you doing
here what have you been doing since the
goonies are they like not friends now
her hey tell me who that woman was we
just left here and why does she act like
she knows me why you gotta be like that
you know teyla a little too well yeah o
bones nice skin this is where its this
game is weird like really into it uh
chassis you know she in the game you
gotta love
she likes not remember I was this guy
was really the only character i truly
remember he was like a main character
even after all talkable I all right one
more question ladder I'm just intrigued
I don't got a ladder you might want to
check at the golden hair while asking
about a ladder they've been doing a
bunch of renovations all right right
okay bye I can't go to the North Hill
clinic not now I need to investigate the
crime scene to find out what happened
they got him that the exemption behind
rooks pawn shop is a dirty ugly alcove
that reminds me a lot of rookie this
dude's face on this thing I remember the
day I came back to my office to that
grizzly signed flashback had not a
flashback I'm another old Tex Murphy
thing why is that screaming old man's
head in the jar of water right for an
hour to get pugs head out of the water
but it was no dice haha the police
showed up and thought about grilling me
until they realized pug was a mutant and
it was like they couldn't care less I
guess people are a little apprehensive
about taking that bottle back for
deposit so there's my office this is the
electronic shop that had the busted up
windows I feel like we should probably I
need to get in I don't think you can get
in there though that's oh that's why you
did get the ladder right to get to the
window right for that window okay yeah
we've already been back here so where
did he say the ladder was oh yeah hotel
excuse some random voice in the back of
our hash has told us that it might be
though it's out snow white warehouse we
believe has a ladder so it's just a case
of finding this key she was talking
about um where did you say they hid
doesn't wear outside the door there
needs a key that's where you put the key
there you go we're we got here it's like
instructions to get into the snow white
we're awesome
the code for 26 acres 88
needs a key and you'd find the code
thing okay adore when visiting salt lake
so in busy beautiful sake that came to
visit and let on the tail of it Oh San
Francisco is a key to a long locks what
we have a code and a key to some god
this is confusing don't we have a code
to lockbox already is the key oh oh oh
right okay he opens the box to oh yeah
kozhhikode yeah that's how hmm 46 eight
I really appreciate like deus ex 1 style
that i had open thanks yeah i had to do
that like you never in thief we did this
oh yeah thank you and then i actually
have to press the eyes yeah 4268 I like
that too it's creepy why I was just
still here I used this to deal with a
cunning criminal on my under a Killing
Moon case who had a bad case I think
we've got a flashback hair yeah look I
must start so janky oh I want to hear
it's supposed to be what do you remember
the composite you still not enough Lou
now that i have a ladder i can get into
the second floor the Electronic Show
please disregard for inventory aha I
like it yeah carrying a lot off with a
letter my backpack what the ding ding
wash oh I can interact with it ah are
you betting on a horse oh this must be
some sort of get Oh like a mini game am
I supposed to be following the oh is it
Simon Says I think it is blue purple yes
all right all right yeah yeah and there
you go with Oh which is Duda there's a
dude with no pants on
huh
don't don't shoot
walk walk around where he's hiding the
gun at least so theatrical like yeah and
then I think it's like it's a lot of
cartoony yeah I mean it's very cartoony
rot ro o finish day one at the end of
this day I get to sex with that coffee
girl so that was awesome cost if he
could help me break it then I'd be
impressed I really enjoyed that so high
yeah that was your first text Murphy
experience rack I mean I was
surprisingly into that there was a p.i
raging current path i don't know i was
expecting some jank and there is like a
fair maybe there's no magical way around
its life storytelling has done pretty
well yes so it takes pretty good well
written i felt like it was a world that
was like beyond considering hair like
small that little area they were letting
you play in was I felt it felt like a
world that was beyond its borders that
kept going yeah yeah as somebody who's
played the old games and was clearly
getting some nice as I started with ya
do you think you're gonna play this I
think I'm gonna actually I want to see I
want to know how long it is first
because I don't want to play very much
time in it but I think I die I want to
give it a shot and I want to play some
days probably thank you very much
everyone Benito thank you very much
trying a knife sure thanks Madeline then
it wouldn't have been the same with su
this is a very much a game that you need
somebody with nostalgia hooks to kind of
let you know a bit and don't know what's
all next we're gonna show as ever at Don
you are on twitter if you have any
suggestions and thanks for hanging out
see you next week bye